good morning very difficult to follow
these incredible speakers oh my god such
I'm still just absorbing Stacy's stories
so it's have to kind of make this
transition have to use my skills and and
Suzanne who I know well and we've taught
many times together I just it's just
fantastic to hear you talk about this
which I've never heard you talk about
before and to hear again about these
butter sculptures in Minnesota because I
you always teach about them and I've
just still never seen one but I you
showed a picture I appreciate it
thank you thank you where I grew up in
Oregon it was rose festival princesses
it was not the butter Queens or whatever
they are
I want to thank sort of a heartfelt
thanks to a very old friend in the DBT
world and in my life as Perry Hoffman
who has not only persisted in developing
this organization with a lot of people
some of whom are here and and it's just
the beginning of what this organization
is gonna be able to do I think it's just
amazing what you've done and and her
persistence in pursuing me to speak at
one of these but she's done for ten
years and I think this is the first one
so I don't know how you did it but she
just doesn't give up which is really
impressive and and talented the way she
does it and her colleagues do it so it's
amazing what's happened and I and the
people who ran the conference and and
kept persisting and getting me to send
in my talk and my title and my slides
and everything else so thank you for
persisting this is Nicole Emily
everybody who's done this and a
heartfelt thanks to Seth
for putting this together over and over
again and having the the kind of grace
and persistence that he has you know and
just thinking that he's working on a
recovery and in a medical condition so
really thinking of him and appreciating
him so Thank You Seth for me this is a
nostalgia attack is happening when I
walked in here because in 1972 on July
1st I sat in this auditorium in my first
day as a Yale medical student and so
here I am again it was just amazing to
walk back in here and see that the
campus and and be back in this room
which I haven't been in for 30-some
years and so it's really cool for me to
be able to speak here and to have a
bunch of friends here from different
parts of my personal and work life and I
wanted to tell I got caught in this
little nostalgia loop here and I
realized as I was thinking that that my
roots of being a DBT therapist and
teacher really went back away before DBT
and by telling a brief story I think you
sort of capture for those of you who are
learning about DBT might capture sort of
what might be in it that would be
appealing to somebody who actually was
originally trained psychoanalytically me
I was at Yale Medical School and by the
end of you know medical school I was
thinking I wanted to be a psychiatrist
and a psychotherapist and I became I
went into psychoanalytic treatment and
training and itself it was so weird to
go into psychoanalysis it was the only
time I set up an appointment at the
beginning of my last year of medical
school I interviewed psychoanalysts I
picked one that I would work with as
part of also my psychoanalytic training
also personal psychoanalysis and we
agreed on a date
a year and a half in the future at 6:15
in the morning and we never spoke again
until that day and I showed up and he
showed up Wow
this was like never anything like this
so that was the beginning of my
psychoanalysis while I was in
psychoanalysis maybe one or two years in
I was talking with him about the fact
that when I was a little kid I was the
slowest runner in my class
and when we ran across the gym floor in
third grade in my little school little
town not not quite as small as as
Stacie's town but almost I was the last
to finish I was even behind Holly
Sparkman who was tall and gangly and and
I thought and she and I were like
considered a pair like here's the slow
kids and there it was no problem if you
weren't thinking of becoming a
professional athlete but I was I was
already thinking I wanted to be
I admired Bill Bradley Larry Bird I was
going to be the next slow white guy that
would play in the NBA and and I buy by
the time I was in fourth grade I was a
gym rat I knew every gym in town that's
where I spent all my spare time was
playing basketball and just pushing
pushing pushing for that and trying to
get faster and and I worked at it and at
a certain key moment in seventh grade my
father I can't believe he did it when I
think back on it but he took me for a
Saturday appointment to the track coach
at University of Oregon who was a famous
track coach for milers and quarter-mile
IRS's Bill Bowerman and this guy watched
me run and gave me a prescription of
what I should do over the next year to
get faster and to jump higher because I
actually had the rest of the game was
developing pretty well it certainly had
the passion so for the next year every
day I'd get up early before school and
I'd go out to the track which was right
next to my house because I was next to a
school and I'd run the 440 and I would
hop on one foot around the 440 hop on
the other foot around the 440 hop on
both feet around the fort
forty run wind sprints and then finish
off with a bunch of 440s
then at night I would jump rope for now
and I just devoted and I buy within
about two years I had the strongest legs
you ever saw and I was no faster like
you realize I mean the coach didn't
grasp the difference in physiology
between the neuromuscular junctions
which were genetically programmed to
never fire very quick and strength which
is a different thing so I had really
strong slow legs and I was no faster and
by the time I was about sixteen and I
was not a starter on the varsity at my
high school I thought I it really was a
dream that died very painfully as I
realized this is not happening and so
I'm telling my psychoanalyst about all
this telling him the story and and as he
sat there behind me as I was laying on
the couch at 6:15 in the morning and at
a certain point I said you know and I'm
still so slow I go out I run around the
track at Yale the Yale Bowl it's called
where all the athletic fields are I
would go out there every afternoon every
evening I would do whenever I got time I
would go be running and then I would run
in these community races for a mile or
five miles or something like that and I
was always kind of slow so I started
talking to him about I've worked so hard
at this and it's never changed and it
was such a crushing blow when I was 16
and you know I don't know what what to
do you know and I was 30 31 years old at
that point and at a certain point he
said after it's not saying anything for
a while which actually I found very
helpful because most people around me
talk too much and he said he said but
what makes you think you're so slow and
I thought did I hear that right I said
because I am slow I said because I am
slow because I run the 440 in
such-and-such the mile in such-and-such
the hundred yard dash and such-and-such
for somebody who has spent this amount
of time and who wanted to be a
professional athlete I'm incredibly slow
do you understand that
long pause but what makes you
think you're so slow thought oh my god I
mean did I not make this clear and I
said have you never been on an athletic
field do you have you never been to an
athletic event and I started to demean
him for how short he was and he was
round and he smoked cigarettes and I
thought this man this is the wrong
psychoanalyst for me I need a sort of a
small town Oregon guy not a New York
Jewish guy who's going to like never get
this and so I was really upset and then
I said to I said it again I said let me
make myself perfectly clear if you run
the hundred yard dash in eighteen
seconds after you've devoted thousands
of hours to it that's really slow What
did he say after a pause what makes you
think you are so slow he really did this
it's a real story
I mean he's dead now so I could say
whatever I want but it's actually true
he was he was down the street from here
and so I thought did this man have a
stroke
this is like this is this what you call
perseveration so I keep saying this and
think and so I stopped talking about it
but what did I do
I actually in my running at the Yale
Bowl I saw this guy there who I had seen
there a lot he was a Yale athlete he was
a track athlete he went out there he was
like a serious track athlete you knew
this guy's serious he showed up with
sunglasses on and he would take him off
and he would put everything in a pile
and he had a whole routine and he'd work
out and and I thought this guy knows
what he's doing and I went to him and I
said would you watch me run and tell me
if there's anything I can do about it to
get faster this guy takes me under his
wing it was like just a perfect moment I
mean this guy's apparently was looking
for somebody to mentor and so he watches
me run and he was very he acted very
non-judgmental god knows what he told
his friends but he would say he'd say no
there are several things you can do
first of all you're running like a very
tall goose
you know like
and so and you just you know that it
it's it's somehow you got in your head
that that's how you run that you stay
standing up you lean back you take long
strides and you look all over the place
this is like exactly wrong you have to
lean forward to the point that you
actually think you might fall down if
you don't take the next step you have to
look straight ahead and never to decide
you have to take short choppy steps that
as a tall person you need to know that
you have to take steps that feel way too
short and way too fast and you have to
think of where you're going and how to
get there in other words seriously he
gave me very specific he sort of did
skills training for somebody like me to
try to run and then he watched me and
then he coached me and then he saw me
the next day and within two months of
working with him I was actually I
dramatically changed my times it was
like totally memorable I mean a turning
point for me to think that you can
change something this refractory in such
a short time if you do it the right way
if you have this combination of somebody
who motivates you which is what I would
say my psychoanalyst actually was a
brilliant motivator maybe that wasn't
his point I mean his point was he was
focused on intrapsychic life he was
focused on how I experienced myself and
actually his question of what makes you
think you're so slow it could have been
what makes you think you're so slow or
could have been what makes you think
you're so slow or what makes you think
you're so slow or whatever in other
words he was like trying to penetrate my
rigid wall of belief that I couldn't be
any faster and my parents gave me the
wrong neuromuscular junctions and they
were to blame and there was nothing to
be done about it and it ruined my life I
mean he was like listening he was
actually listening I valued it enormous
Lee it may sound like I'm making fun of
a psychoanalyst but actually it was
brilliant it was brilliant and it got me
it penetrated my wall of belief that I
could not perform and after that I met
the other guy in the treatment the
skills trainer
so I had a psychoanalyst on a skills
trainer in the same treatment they
didn't know each other they didn't care
about each other they were totally
pursuing different goals one actually
wanted me to run faster and the other
one was trying to sort of penetrate
through the way I thought about myself
and actually I got fast enough believe
this if you know any any times in a mile
run in New Haven not you know two three
months later I ran a mile in 535 which
is the fastest I ever did which was
unbelievable to me never could I have
imagined doing that I was 32 or 33 then
I thought Larry Bird retired at 33 I
mean maybe there's still a chance yes if
I still can the end of my potential
career but I didn't pursue it instead I
went into something that requires no
speed at all which is psychiatry and so
I still write up to last night continue
to watch and admire and envy some of
these athletes but you know I try to do
my own thing my own way
now that's DBT before DBT was
constructed Linehan was constructing it
during those very years actually but
what is that what is DBT there it is
that it's a treatment that attends to
your capabilities which means how do you
do things effectively if you know what
you're trying to do how do you get there
how do you get from here to there and it
attends to your motivation it's like
your thinking your emotions everything
that's getting in your way
so that you can't even think that you
can get there it's supposed to attend to
motivation and capability and I didn't
realize that at a time but that was such
a formative experience for me to think
back on that whole thing that I thought
you know it doesn't this is not a very
interesting thing for a clinician to
treat compared to things where people
are ruining their lives but it was sort
of a model for it for me the next thing
I want to tell you very briefly because
that I want to cover some slides my
point today is going to be to sort of
try to get the essence of DBT across and
then rapidly go through the progress in
DBT since it began and talk about where
we're at where the trend
are where I think it's going some of the
things that are coming going along now
you just think now I think that I think
it's actually given a time I should
probably just jump that head and then if
I get him get a few minutes I'll come
back there's the story of how I went
from running a psychoanalytic inpatient
unit with Otto Kern Berg as my mentor to
discovering DBT and then moving on and
trying out DBT and ending up thinking I
would do it for two or three years and
then then it here it is 25 years later
having written an article then about the
difference between kernberg and Linney
hence models so in 1989 it was published
really trying to figure out the
differences of these things I'm in a
different place now as Lois Choi cane
could tell you she's a presenter this
afternoon she and I an article recently
looking at mentalization and DBT and so
to try I'm always interested in the
ingredients of different models that
actually help people move forward rather
than getting stuck in any one package
though today now back into my package
DBT let me go over some slides see if I
can do this as well as Susanna Twitter
hold the technological genius of your
welcome in the beginning
meaning the 1980s
DBT was an outpatient treatment for para
suicidal behaviors and that's been
discussed for women with borderline
personality disorder what was it at that
point in time you know just to lay it
out as simply as possible it was that
the patient there were four things that
went on every week there was individual
therapy every week there was skills
training every week for the patients
there was a telephone consultation every
whenever needed which was calling the
therapist and getting coaching in the
moment to use skills when facing
difficult situations
there was the therapists getting
together every week and supporting each
other and trying to stay adherent and
stay on track and keep learning the
treatment support each other in the
treatment there was a list of treatment
targets that Suzanne went over earlier
sort of prioritized so that if he
started out with all those pieces of in
her nice picture there you know you
figure out which ones to prioritize over
which others so that you go step by step
so it's not only a dual diagnosis it's a
trio diagnosis to multiple diagnosis
treatment so that the patients that in
my work for which for many years has
been to be medical director of the
department of mental health in western
and central Massachusetts and oversee
the clinical system there in the public
sector where if somebody's highly
suicidal and they have a substance abuse
program problem they can't get into a
substance abuse program because they're
suicidal and they can't get into a
suicide treatment program because
they're still actively using and so it's
like this standard problem that DBT is a
multiple yes your substance abusing
you're doing this you're doing this it's
all in the same treatment but we have to
do it in order of priority you there are
certain standard agreements certain
standard assumptions there's a protocol
for how to manage and assess suicidal
crises and there's three basic sets of
strategies problem-solving strategies
that are based on cognitive behavioral
therapy validation and acceptance
strategies that at their deepest
probably are based on mindfulness and
and and various sources of mindfulness
including Zen and dialectical philosophy
as brought to life in treatment in a way
that again I think Suzanne nicely
explained the total focus of that
therapy from the beginning was that the
therapist focused relentlessly
persistently on reducing high-risk
behaviors in a way that Stacy I think
nicely captured when she was saying what
she heard from her DBT therapist of what
was expected yes you can do this reminds
me of kids playing hockey and there was
a professional wrestler that was the
father of the goalie on my older son's
hockey team in high school and I would
stand there next to the
guy who had the Mohawk and yet tattoos
and he was like really like big-time
professional wrestler you stand there
like this and his son as goalie if his
son ever looked like he wasn't going to
get up after a terrible hit it's he
would yell out to him say you have a
broken neck
somebody break your spine any other
reason to stay down that's like I mean
he had that quality but he didn't have
that compassion part you know that was
the other part so just he had a piece he
had a piece of it but he needed to go
through another lifetime I think to sort
of put it together so it turned out that
was the package by the way realize the
package was very specific in those days
it was treatment for women treatment for
women with suicidal behavior treatment
for women with suicidal behavior and
other features of borderline personality
disorder and it was a treatment of an
outpatient clinic and it was a once a
week cycle therapy and it was a certain
this this and this in other words it was
very specified so anything you did
outside of that wasn't the package it
was experimental in those days so that
was you know late 1980s actually the
first manual I got from Lynn ahem is
that when I started doing DBT on an
inpatient unit and she sent me her quote
manual in 1987 which was from 1984 and
it was just a pile of papers and it was
hard to even talk with her about when I
wanted to talk with her about a certain
thing in there because I'd talked to her
on the phone and say Marcia what this
thing will you call radical acceptance
really what is this I mean how do you
really get this across and in those days
she was doing the only DBT in the world
it was not outside of her lab actually
the the program I developed in White
Plains was the first DBT application
outside of her lab in the world and so
she loved the doctor from New York is
talking to her so she'd be on the phone
anytime I wanted and I'd say Marcia this
radical she'd say which page is that on
and
about every page was page one so it was
I would have to she would find it though
and we would talk and so that was the
first manual was the 1984 unpublished
thing which is way bigger than the
manual that came later in 1993 and so in
those days it was a manualized very
specific treatment it didn't have other
things that you did it didn't have other
patient populations so that's part of
where things have changed so
dramatically and what did it do that
package well it did these things in the
first studies the first published study
in 1991 in the archives of General
Psychiatry which was kind of amazing to
have a female psychologist publish a
psychotherapy study in the archives of
General Psychiatry she was turned down
three times and she just knew that's
where it had to be because she had a
sense of this has to get out there in
the world as you probably most of you
probably know her own mission from the
time she was 8 19 or 20 years old had
become how to go back in and get other
people out of hell so she's like pushing
pushing for that so she gets it in the
archives she publishes this she has
follow-up studies she shows that
actually compared to treatment as usual
you can do all of these things which
your standard things have been discussed
many times I just want you to notice at
the bottom the misery remained that was
one of the interesting findings of her
studies there's all these dramatic
behavioral changes but people were still
often reporting as much depression as
much anxiety in as much hopelessness
over the past 20 years these findings
have been replicated more than a dozen
times we actually more than 18 times as
as we speak right now in randomized
controlled trials that just keep showing
this package works this package works
this package works in those studies we
learned very important other things that
aren't usually the first stated findings
they include the following what you
choose to target matters in other words
if you're doing DBT but you're not it's
a DBT for suicidal behavior you're just
not really especially focusing on
substance abuse don't expect it to get
better same with eating disorders that
actually it matters if you include
something like substance abuse or eating
disorders in your
program chances are you're gonna figure
out how to improve it so that this was
an this isn't important finding and I
think in any treatment actually Hilda
Brook found this as a psychoanalytic
therapist for eating disorders is that
she was doing she noticed other
psychoanalysts doing standard
psychoanalysis trying to look at the
underpinnings of eating disorders and
she added in a component where you
actually focus directly on the behavior
of an eating disorder and she started to
get good findings and I just think it's
a it's something to keep in mind
adherence to the manual matters at least
in DBT and I think every every treatment
needs to study this about whether it
actually matters if you're adherent to
the treatment and adherence is hard to
define but Linehan has worked her butt
off to try to define it it's just really
really a complicated treatment
validation matters
it matters more than Linehan first
thought it would think it's fair to say
this i used to teach a lot with her and
trained with her at the beginning and
you know her idea at the beginning was
more that validation is the sugar
coating this was her metaphor because
the bitter pill of cognitive behavioral
therapy is often hard to swallow so but
that's the change ingredient so you need
validation enough validation in order to
get the medicine to go down in other to
get get somebody to participate in
problem-solving in their lives actually
it turns out over these subsequent years
validation in its own right
now there's much more research on that
and a validation in his own right is a
change agent it is a change agent it
helps people a Moute emotionally
regulate probably better than almost any
other single strategy that we've got in
DBT DBT reduces the overall cost of
treatment which is a little paradoxical
to insurance companies because actually
upfront it costs a little more than what
they're usually paying for but if they
look over a period of a year of people
who have suicidal behavior they're going
to save money generally because of the
loss reduction in hospitalization
reducing high-risk behaviors doesn't
necessarily reduce misery
or longer term life dysfunction this has
been seen in study after study and in
marries a Noreen ease work and following
at MacLean Hospital following the longer
term that you know you get better in
some ways and then not better in other
ways and that leaves the field groping
with what to do about the remaining axis
one disorders after behaviors under
control or the remaining misery and some
of the other targets that you go after
in stage 2 of DBT which is a hype which
is now a big focus
DBT improves some comorbid disorders
better than others so that you can
typically reduce depression substance
abuse eating disorders if you're
targeting these things but it's not
unusual for high levels of anxiety and
PTSD to remain after you've solved other
problems in your life so that's just an
important thing because then you really
have to up the ante a little bit on
treating anxiety disorders and PTSD
meanwhile DB T's bio social theory and
in the interest of time I I won't be
able to go over that here but in a
nutshell you heard a little about it
this morning which is that it's the
theory that says that if you have a fair
amount of emotional intensity or
sensitivity or reactivity and you grow
up in an environment that doesn't
validate that and invalidates that that
actually you get stuck in a trap the
trap of continuing to have those
emotional responses cognitive responses
and being in a situation where
pervasively there's no one around you
that's validating that and saying well
of course you have feel that way and yes
let's figure out what to do about it
in other words if there's a big mismatch
you get stuck in this trap that becomes
almost like its own tell that continues
and perpetuates and and can get worse
over time if you don't get that
validation and effective treatment so
that it meanwhile the biosocial Theory
has been increasingly under study
physiologically and subjectively for
years now and just it looks like most
elements of the theory are getting
validated but I won't go more into that
that's sort of
where we're at as a field right now is
that this theory that was put together
in the 80s by Linehan turns out to have
been a pretty good rough way to start
and the specifics are getting clearer
recent trends in DBT this is kind of a
table of contents of the next few
minutes of this talk so this is like a
header slide one thing is the
extraordinary extension of DBT in the
world I mean I wrote a commentary in a
publication about 15 years ago about
what makes DBT so popular because
actually it started being in popular
before the data came out and then even
when there was only one study it started
to be treated as if something that had
15 studies behind it it was like amazing
to me as somebody who came from another
very challenging amazing and esteemed
treatment which was Kern Berg's work to
go out and teach a DBT workshop in the
Upper Peninsula of Michigan and meet up
with somebody who's a graduate student
of Marshall in Hamm and 400 goddamn
people show up it's like we flew over
trees that's all we saw I thought who's
gonna nobody had heard of DBT thought
who's gonna show up to a DBT workshop in
Bismarck or Port Huron or whatever it
was then
well 400 people are there that Wow and I
talked from a lot of clinical experience
and the graduate student talked from a
lot of teaching and one patient and
everybody was like knocked out and I
thought what is this this is like a hoax
that everybody's getting that now it's
like the best you know it's the only
hoax in the world with 18 randomized
controlled trials behind it I think but
oh my god the dissemination the the
interest in it went beyond the data
and in the thing I wrote then I thought
as I really sort of took stock of what
seemed to be that people found so
gripping about this treatment was first
of all we had an unsolved problem that
caused an enormous amount of suffering
patients clinicians families communities
hospital administrators it was like this
was not solved I was secondly it
the in the era that we're in to put
together a treatment that includes
evidence-based practices of behaved from
behavioral treatments to really change
behavior along with studies of motion
regulation in the brain along with
mindfulness practices that most people
at that point thought oh yeah I remember
when I practice Transcendental
Meditation or what did yoga but like to
take that seriously and integrate that
into a treatment and to take seriously
the invalidating environment and Studies
on trauma and the treatment of trauma
and put that all in the same package and
add into it support for the therapists
so that they can keep giving support to
the patient was like I just thought
people were very captivated by this and
then the data started coming out and
just I think has kept it going
increased focus on emotion dysregulation
topic number two here big trend is that
even though that's been part of the
theory from the beginning is that you
have emotion dysregulation is that the
core of the disorder from a DBT
therapists point of view is that you're
you're seeing the emotion dysregulation
coming about because of a sort of a
sensitive emotionally disregulated
nervous system to begin with and an in
validating environment you end up with
chronic severe emotion dysregulation and
that is the infrastructure for the rest
of the problems that come up that was
always part of the theory but actually
in the last five years the focus on the
treatment of emotion dysregulation has
done more and more in center stage and
now with more data behind it so that
actually we find that DBT and sense in
particular certain aspects of skills
training reduce emotion dysregulation
now that it's a construct that's
increasingly measurable and and if you
can increase emotion dysregulation it
turning turning out that you can
decrease the high risk behaviors that go
with it of course so that the increased
focus on emotion dysregulation and
linkages with studies by biologists
neurobiologists of emotion dysregulation
is just like something that's a strong
trend in DBT if you go to any
DBT conference where new stuffs being
presented you're just everything
starting to get framed in that way
getting studied that way so that's a big
trend efficacy of skills only DBT is a
package right after being validated as a
whole package many many times of course
the next research step is to figure out
what it is in that package that actually
is helpful what are the active
ingredients in this complex package if
you can figure out what the active
ingredients are the core components as
implementation specialists call them if
you can figure out the core components
you can probably develop a more
efficient treatment you can probably
narrow down on the things that seem to
have the most bang for the buck and
really go for it so you know DBT still
had in a sense an early stage of
dismantling studies to figure out which
elements of this treatment actually are
needed are actually the strongest and is
there a better way to put them together
so coming out of that right now and
there have been several different types
of dismantling studies the the I think
most surprising finding tool in ahem she
gave a talk in November at the ABC tea
meeting sociation for behavior and
cognitive therapy where she was asked in
stage one of these big big things with
thousand or so people you know what do
you think in your 40 years of doing this
work has been the biggest surprise in
your career and she said the biggest
surprises recently the last 10 years
starting to see that skill packages that
are mainly skills training are way more
effective than I thought they would be I
thought you needed the whole package
individual therapy skills training all
the coaching the teams and everything
and now actually there's several studies
out about that focused more on the
delivery of skills along with some of
the aspects of DBT but not everything
that are turning out to be pretty
effective so those are I'll get back to
this the next one is the potency of
validation as a treatment tool and also
the potency of invalidation as a
destructive force some of the they're
been just more and more studies and I
think that trend is continuing and
finally the increased focus on PTSD
within DBT and how to treat that it's
always been there but actually there
hasn't been a model for it until
recently and now I think that model is
just gaming legs more and more and I
think we're gonna see more and more of
that now to cover some of these more in
more detail that wasn't my last slide
know how all right is that the next or
did I go too far there dissemination
this is how my computer at home works
you click and then you tune in tomorrow
okay I think I'm now it's going to go
past that because I clicked again let's
see dissemination of DBT I already said
some things about it but just a few
things about it 25 years of
dissemination continues around the world
I'm just stunned by it myself I do
training and other places I currently am
overseeing an implementation in northern
Italy I'm overseeing an implementation
in the western part of Sweden places
where there hasn't been almost any DBT
and people are just as excited as
anybody's ever been about it and there's
much more to bring to them I've just I'm
in the middle of an implementation with
Kaiser Permanente Foundation in the
mid-atlantic states where we're doing
Virginia Maryland and DC and they're
doing a mainly skills only model
throughout Kaiser they're and they're
really doing it well and they're getting
really good training I mean so it just
keeps going oh it's just been quite
quite amazing
I was once having lunch with David
Barlow who as many of you know is sort
of one of the deans of psychology in the
world and of anxiety disorders treatment
and we were at a conference like this
we're having lunch and he said it's like
ten years ago he said could you tell me
something why do why is it that I've
developed a treatment that has 35
randomized controlled trials that works
every time it's fantastic it changes
people's lives and it isn't anywhere out
there and DBT that has five goddamn
studies is everywhere every county in
the United States has DBT what is this
so there is something very interesting I
was I was called to Austin Riggs
Hospital a few year
ago to spend a whole day consulting with
him about what is DBT but also I thought
the underlying agenda was to find out
for me how did we market it so
effectively we've gotten smarter about
implementation I've done a lot of
implementation so we gotten smarter to
figure out how to really make a high
quality implementation happen and also
we've seen more and more hazards of
widespread implementation it went way
ahead of the data it went way ahead of
good training techniques so people are
out there doing it doing what they think
is DBT they call DBT and then it doesn't
work and then it means DBT doesn't work
and the whole world of serious DBT
implementers are just suffering with
finding out how much DBT is claimed to
be going on but if you watch it it's not
DBT so there this has been a big problem
of success BPD advocacy has grown more
influential this organization NDA BPD
has just been incredible in continuing
or beginning and continuing advocacy the
fact that Nami embraced borderline
personality disorder as a biologically
based condition that they support which
also was from advocacy groups like any a
BPD also Tara is another advocacy
organization and a lot of individual
consumers and family members that have
just pushed and pushed and pushed to try
to get this acknowledge so that there
could be funding for this I think this
the influential of advocacy groups the
influence has just been huge training
options and vehicles have proliferated
and just rapidly the computerization of
training figuring out how that fits in
with in-person training figuring out how
to put it on smartphones applications of
DBT of which there's now several and
then this new journal that also is
co-sponsored by NEA BPD that's really
just coming out everybody should tune
into this pay attention this and get it
because it the people running it I mean
the people who are the editorial board
with the Martin boja and John Oldham and
small from Germany this is going to be a
fantastic journal that brings together
not just DBT but issues about emotion
dysregulation and borderline personality
disorder so keep your eye out for that
it's now you know coming adaptations
about target behaviors other things that
have happened in DBT and I
just seeing Emily walk this way it's
like I've got PTSD already it's like
yeah I have four minutes so the original
target was Paris suicidal behaviour but
where are we today 25 years later
essentially well now there's the
substantial evidence base for the
treatment of substance abuse there's a
substantial evidence base for the
treatment of binge eating and purging
behaviors and both of these along with
borderline personality disorder there's
this a preliminary sub evidence base for
treating sort of cynicism depression and
rigidity in people who are older who
have a depression and and they're just
carrot you know they're not they're not
doing the things that would help make
them better turns out that in
preliminary studies that DBT skills
training was helpful for them PTSD
within border of the borderline spectrum
there's preliminary evidence where of
that I'll get back to that that actually
we can really start to change that
bipolar disorder there's preliminary
evidence that the applications of DBT
modified for bipolar actually can be
helpful ADHD in adolescents and adults
problem there's a lot of always people
have cited the overlap between ADHD
symptom atala G and borderline
symptomatology and they're often
traveling together and when you start to
look more and more at teenagers and
younger kids you really see this
happening and so you know applying DBT
to try to reduce the symptomatology of
ADHD it turns out that there is
preliminary evidence that that's how is
helpful also oppositional defiant
disorder in teenagers and also anorexia
nervosa has never really been a target
so much of of DBT which has really been
more of a focusing on behaviors of diss
control out of control but it's been a
little bit of a stretch to apply it to
disorders of over control restricting
eating as opposed to losing control of
your eating so now though there is an
application by one of the DBT researcher
Tom Lynch
out there that's starting to look like
okay let's there's probably a little bit
of pilot evidence that this may turn out
to be helped
this sort of DBT for disorders of over
control and it's at least for now in the
pug the book isn't out yet I'm actually
reviewing the book but it's it's the
provisional title is radically open DBT
and I don't know if it'll keep being
called that adaptations other than
target behaviors are going to be
arriving on your local screen at any
moment because I click this a while ago
there is populations a theater near you
will have this so in addition how where
else has DBT been being adapted it's
being adapted to adolescents with
suicidal behaviors and while there was
pilot evidence it's now traveled all
over the world
people are doing it without much
evidence but now there's two major
multi-site studies that are generating
evidence one on the west coast of the
United States and one in Norway where
actually the data is looking really good
for treating suicidal and impulsive
adolescents families with members
diagnosed with BPD so that you have the
family connections work that have been
supported in part of any a BPD's mission
and Alan frees Eddie's mission has been
helping people also populations like
couples with domestic abuse again Alan
frazzetti s work with that population of
people both the abusers and the victims
how how emotion dysregulation plays a
role in the family system and how
addressing that might reduce domestic
violence juvenile offenders in
residential settings there are several
applications pre-adolescent children now
and
paraplegic ova who I think is here right
Francesca is here right there yeah is is
sort of taking the lead in this really
interesting modifications of DBT to
apply to pre-adolescent kids and there's
some literature out on it there's a
grant
underway right to grandson under way so
you know what pardon
one to Diana NIH and I've seen other
applications for children that are
really interesting but now it's being
studied right here intellectual
disabilities the application to
cognitive impairments intellectual
disabilities that Julie brown has done
and I think she presented that actually
at a previous NEA bepd meeting didn't
she
Mary yeah caregivers for partners of
individuals with dementia there's a DBT
application somebody's done with that
that group and teens with poor
compliance to medical protocols one of
the most touching studies you'll ever
hear about if you haven't heard how many
of them know about this study from New
York about kids that keep getting bumped
off the list to get kidney transplants
you don't know about this there's been
it's what it's published it was this
series of six kids but this is what in
the group that works with Alec Miller
kids that are in the hospital that are
have kidney failure and they're on
dialysis and they get put they get
bumped off the list for kidney because
of their behavioral issues you have to
meet certain criteria of compliance and
staying on the list so the application
of DBT in an 8 or 12 week application
with these kids got six out of six kids
to be able to be back on the list and
get kidney transplants just like oh my
god so the application of DBT within
medical non-compliance I think is the
broader issue and now you are really
serious over there I see you there and
final one I'll mention here and then I'm
gonna stop and take questions and I
think I've got you know more slides but
what the hell they're just slides
is public sector clients which have been
a passion of my I'm a centerpiece of my
work people who get stuck in the mental
health system and can't even think that
they could get out of the mental health
system they don't even know how to ask
that question because their life has
become the mental health system and Kate
come tois in Washington started taking
that in a very systematic serious way to
develop aces ACPs accepting the
challenge of exiting the system which is
just a brilliant application of DBT to
help people go from being embedded in
the system to working their way out as a
target as a goal so really interesting
applications and I'm going to stop there
to take questions and then we do have a
panel at the end of the day I'll also be
here for that so do you do we have time
all right so please pass your questions
to the aisles and we will run them up
you actually touched on something that
is a question we have there are
questions about DBT to treat couples so
do you know of any extensions that are
not specific to domestic abuse that
might be more general for what for
working with couples
treating couples in yeah you know I
think here though a number of people
have done this and I've done this might
in my own work because I work with
couples and families so I apply it in
various ways that I think the person
who's most systematically been
developing this is Alan Rosetti who
actually wrote a book and published it
many years ago called the high conflict
couple which is really about how you
treat a high conflict couple with using
the basic construct of emotion
dysregulation as the problem and the use
of creating a validating environment as
a prerequisite and how to really focus
on that it's really a great application
of DBT and it's been there for quite a
while so that's where I would suggest
you go next
excellent we have a question wondering
if the skills only approach that you
were talking about do you think it could
be applied in a prevention focus maybe
taught in schools churches at a
community setting so do you know of any
work on that yeah and so a great
question and there is work on that and
there'll be actually there'll be a
manual published in a few months on this
by Jim Massa and his wife Liz Dexter
maza you can look for that and for
middle school in high school it is a
curriculum and a manual for how to bring
it into the schools both implementation
within a school because that's very
challenging again like the thing with
children like the thing with other
populations a lot of people are actually
doing it in schools now in my area in
western Massachusetts there's quite a
number of schools that are now doing
more and more DBT skills either at
after-school programs
or during lunch or building it within
wellness or health classes and now
there'll be this curriculum that's
really well researched and it's this is
really going to revolutionize it so I
think there's enormous pull for it and
the idea of prevention
goes nicely with other things that came
up earlier today so yes it's out there
look for Jim Mozza amazes ea I actually
think you can already even order the
book on Guilford press but it isn't out
there yet um related to that to the
skills only approach can you clarify
what components of DBT are omitted when
that you're doing skills overlap because
it's one thing to just say skills only
approach but actually what we've seen so
far and the serious way to do a skills
only approach which is what we're trying
to do at Kaiser in the place as I
mentioned and where they and that
they've demonstrated to work in Canada
and to the University of Toronto with
Shelley macmaine's more recent study is
that you do include their whole package
of skills training you do include the
therapists have a team meeting so the
consultation team is still included you
still include coaching in between
sessions by telephone though actually in
Shelley macmaine study in Canada there
was very little of that that actually
went on even though they were ready to
handle it and still the findings were
good so that actually was mostly skills
and finally it includes the therapists
knowing the suicide crisis protocol to
assess identify and manage a high
suicide risk if you put that package
together what are you leaving out you're
leaving out individual therapy conducted
according to the DBT manual you might
have a different individual therapy but
so mainly the thing you're leaving out
is the really DBT based individual
therapy okay we're getting some great
questions I don't know if I'll have time
to get to all of them and if so then
we'll definitely bring them up to the
panel what would you do differently for
someone who's already in DBT for
symptoms of PTSD is there something you
would do differently so somebody enters
DBT and they are and they have a lot of
dysregulated behaviors a lot of pain a
lot of sufferings going on and they're
to some degree out of control in their
life and they have PTSD and that's part
of the picture they're having flashbacks
they're having nightmares they're having
intrusive thoughts they get caught in
these
memory traps that they get into they get
triggered into things so this is not an
unusual group within the borderline
personality disorder population right so
what do you do if you know somebody has
PTSD from the beginning well I think
first of all you orient the patient that
you're going to treat the whole thing
that that is central to the treatment is
treating PTSD because some people enter
DBT and say you're telling me I just
have to learn skills and I know we're
not telling you that we're telling you
you have to learn skills on the way to
becoming more resilient on the way to
treating the things that have caused
your suffering in your life and if
that's PTSD for you that's PTSD so the
first important thing is to make it
clear this is within the treatment
package it's a stepwise approach in
treatment it isn't left out a lot of
people bail out of DBT in stage one
because they actually want to talk about
their trauma and the other thing is that
when I work with people that have trauma
based problems when I'm doing the work
in stage one of trying to help them get
their behavior under control over and
over again when we look at scripts of
behavior behavioral shayne analyses you
find here and there and all over the
script there's evidence of the PTSD you
stop right there
you acknowledge it you validate it you
label it you say we're going to treat
this you help with those symptoms right
now and but then you try to get the
person to the point where you can
actually go in more depth and get the
whole story more in a more comprehensive
way within the therapy which is the
treatment of the PTSD along the lines of
the current protocol we've got by
Melanie Harned from Seattle
Oh Melanie is doing the callin next
Sunday night let me just you know she's
fabulous at this and it's really it's a
hype she's hybrid she's created the
synthesis between DBT and prolonged
exposure treatment for trauma and she's
really put them together in a brilliant
way and now she's gathering data for
that so you should tune into that and
that's the NEA Collins series that you
can find the details out for on the NEA
website which you will also find in the
beginning pages of the booklet um last
question for right now before we take a
break for lunch is that we have a
question asking about the effectiveness
of DBT for males suffering from BPD are
you aware of efficacy studies
specifically in males
well what's changed from those first
studies is that males have been included
in most programs and in studies and so
what's what has been noticed in those
studies that have males and females is
that actually the males are doing as
well as the females there's also been
more recent data just epidemiologically
that makes it clearer that whereas we
used to think that about 80% of people
with borderline personality disorder are
females that actually that's not true
that it's closer to 5050 than it looked
if you include things that usually are
sort of male specialties of disorders of
over control certain impulsive behaviors
antisocial behaviors but yes it looks
like the data is just as good for males
as it is for females all right well
thank you very much dr. Scott you're
welcome thank you